[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع العيال
متاحه على الطاوله لمنع ايران من الوصول
لسلاح النووي
في موسم
الحاصل بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
بلنكن العربيه ساتحدث مع الجانبين لخفض
التصعيد
بمسيرات انطلقت من الداخل الايرانيه تاكيد
الامريكي على ان اسرائيل هي من نفذ الهجوم
على اصفهان
وفي كتابه مذكراته ماي بومبيو عمليه قتل
قاسم سليماني استغرقت خمس دقائق فقط
[موسيقى]
اكد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
برينكن في لقاء خاص مع العربيه ان
الولايات المتحده الان تركز على جانب قمع
المظاهرات من قبل النظام الايراني كما شدد
على وجهه نظر الرئيس
في ما يخص البرنامج النووي الايراني
وتناول ايضا ملفات اخرى في المنطقه
نحو الاحداث العديده مثل قمع المظاهرات في
ايران النساء يدافعنا عن حقوقهم ويتم
قمحهن بعنف من قبل النظام وفي نفس الوقت
نرى ايران تدعم روسيا في حربها ضد
اوكرانيا وتقدم لها المسيارات والاسلحه
الاخرى ونرى ايضا ان الدبلوماسيه هي الحل
الوحيد لبرنامج ايران النوويه والرئيس كان
واضح ان كل الحلول مطروحه لمنع ايران من
الحصول على اسلحه النوويه
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه قال ايضا في هذه
المقابله مع العربيه انه سيتحدث مع
الحكومه الاسرائيليه والسلطه الفلسطينيه
لخفض التصعيد ودع كافه الاطراف الى التحلي
بالهدوء
ما يهم هو التحلي بالهدوء وفي الايام
القادمه سنتحدث الى الحكومه الاسرائيليه
والسرطان الفلسطينيه
للحديث اكثر عدد تصعيد الفلسطيني وجهه نظر
الامريكيه وما قاله ابلينكن اليوم ينضم
الينا من القاهره الدكتور جمال عبد الجواد
مستشار مركز الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه
واستراتيجيه الدكتور جمال يعني اليوم امام
هذه الحكومه اليمنيه التي تعتبر الاكثر
يمينا في تاريخ الحكومات الاسرائيليه طبعا
وجهه النظر الامريكيه دائما وخصوصا الحزب
الديمقراطي وهي حلت دولتين الحل السلمي
وعدم التصعيد ويعني التصعيد الكامل بين
الطرفين هل باستطاعات اليوم الامريكي
ايجاد حل وسط بعد التصعيد الحاصل
دعونا نتذكر انه هذه الزياره اللي بقوم
بيها يمكن كانت مقرره سلف انا قبل التصعيد
الاخير لكنها ايضا جايه على خلفيه تصعيد
كبيره حادث ومتواصل خلال العام الاخير
وحتى قبل وصول حكومه نتنياهو الجديده
شديده التطرف الى الحكم الولايات المتحده
في الاداره الجديده همم حريصه على الا
تبتعد عن الشرق الاوسط على ان تكون قريبه
بشكل متكرر ومتواصل مع الحكومات اللي
بتمثل اصدقاء لها في المنطقه فهذا السياق
تاتي الزياره وتاتي
بالمصادفه بعد التصعيد الكبير اللي حصل
خلال الايام ال- ال- القليله الماضيه همم
الولايات المتحده بالتاكيد لها كلمه
مسموعه همم في ال- ال- ال- ال- ال-
العواصم المختلفه حتى لدى اسرائيل حتى لدى
هذه الحكومه اليمنيه لا لا لديها تاثير
لكنها ستدخل في
ومات كبيره بالذات في اسرائيل هذه الحكومه
لديها مطالب من حكومه ديمقراطيه في
الولايات المتحده مطالب تتعلق بايران
مطالب همم تتعلق بالضغط على اسرائيل
ومواصله والمواقف اللي بتتخذها هذه
الاداره من قضايا تتعلق بالاستططان او
بغير فتصور انه نعم ستكون مؤثره لكن بعد
مفاوضات شقه في اسرائيل همم يبقى قضايا
همم سديده الحساسيه او الصعوبه في هذه ال-
ال- في حياه التصعيد الاخير هو انه جانب
كبير من التصعيد فلا من يد التنظيمات
الكبرى والحكومات واصبح في يد اشخاص
منفردين بيتصرفوا وهذا هيصعب المهمه لكن
بالتاكيد الولايات المتحده دورها رئيسه
وزير الخارجيه يعني تقصد عدم الاجابه على
جزئيه اساسيه وموضوع توسيع الاستيطان طبعا
الجانب الامريكي كان اعلن سابقا بانه ضد
هذا الموضوع يعني البؤر على عشوائيه موضوع
غزه موضوع الضفه وغيره بعد سيكون هناك
اجتماعات بهذه الجوله مع الجانب الفلسطيني
والجانب الاسرائيلي وسيكون له طبعا تصريح
بعد هذه الجزئيه بالذات موضوع ال توسيع
الاستيطان ويعني تضييق الخناق على
الفلسطينيين هناك كيف يمكن ان يتعاطى معه
الاداره الامريكيه وكيف ستضغط مع الحكومه
اليمنيه التي رفعت شعارات بهذا الموضوع
حتى ما قبل تشكيل الحكومه
همم اعتقد انه ال- ال- ال- الحكومه
الامريكيه ست- الاداره الامريكيه ستمسك
بموقفها الرافض ليه توسيع الاستيطان
الرافض لاطفاء الشرعي على
المستوطنات غير الشرعيه المنتشره في مناطق
مختلفه في المنطقه جيم على وجه التحديد
همم لكن
بالضغوط الاسرائيليه اظن انه ستصل الحكومه
الامريكيه الى نقطه وسط سنواصل رفض
وانتقاد هذه التصرفات الصينيه الاسرائيليه
لكن ربما لن يترتب على هذا اي اجراء اضافه
في اي اجراء يتعلق بمساعدات او بعقوبات او
ب همم بفرد نوع من انواع التضييق العلاقه
الامريكيه الاسرائيليه وده هيكون موقف
مرضي لحكومه يمنيه في اسرائيل لا تعبه
كثيرا
التصريحات البلاغيه اللي فيها ده هي غير
معنيه بهذا الى حد لكنها معنيه اكثر
بالمثل العلاقه الماديه المواصله الدعم
العسكري التنسيق اكبر في المساله المتعلقه
بالنووي الايراني التشاور اكثر مع اسرائيل
في هذه القضيه هذا هو مهما نتنياهو على
وجه التحديد دكتور جمال هناك جزئيه تتفرع
من هذا الموضوع وهو وهي تعتبر هاجس
بالنسبه للامريكيين موضوع اضعاف سلطه
القضاء وبالتالي التهديد النموذج ديمقراطي
الذي تدعمه همم الحكومه الامريكيه وتحديدا
يعني الحسبه اليوم في اسرائيل هذه الجزئيه
ما هي الرساله التي ممكن ان يوصلها همم
يعني وزير الخارجيه الامريكي بهذا الموضوع
ربما يعني يؤكد على اهميه الاطر المؤسسيه
واحترام القضاء واستقلاليته لكن دعني اقول
من بين ال ال ال القدره على التاثير اللي
بتتمتع بها الولايات المتحده الولايات
المتحده تقول اقل في قدرتها على التاثير
كلما تعلق الامر به اوضاع داخليه اا في
داخل الدول يسري هذا على الدول العربيه
ويسري على اسرائيل وغيرها الصراع الدائر
في اسرائيل الان حوالين القضاء حوالين نقل
اختصاصات من همم من الجهاز القضائي الى
همم البرلمان والى المستوى السياسي همم
هذه الامور تتعلق بالصراع الداخلي في
اسرائيل واتصور انها موضوع التوازن القوه
الداخلي في اسرائيل اكثر منها مساله تتعلق
بالولايات المتحده سيقول الامريكيين رايهم
لكن اظن انه في هذا النوع من القضاء على
وجه التحديد تاثيرهم
يكون سياخذ النظام السياسي الاسرائيلي همم
مساره اللي محكوم بتوازنات القوه الداخليه
شكرا لك يا دكتور جمال عبد الجواد مستشار
مركز الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه حدثتنا من القاهره
وعن العلاقات السعوديه الامريكيه قال
بلنكن للعربيه ان العلاقات بين واشنطن
والسعوديه ثابته وتتطور وامريكا لديها
علاقات مهمه مع السعوديه واشار الى انها
كانت قلقه بالبدايه من قرار اوبك كلاس
بتخفيض انتاج النفط
بورنو
لدينا علاقه مهمه مع السعوديه منذ عقود
واجيال وعبر ادارات امريكيه مختلفه وسنعمل
كل ما بوسعون للتاكد من ان العلاقه مع
الرياض مستمره كان لدينا بعض المخاوف بعد
قرار اوبك بلس تخفيض انتاج النفط منذ ذلك
الحين السعوديه اظهرت على علامات ايجابيه
بدعملها الاوكرانيا ضد الحرب الروسيه
والتاييدها لقرارات مجلس الامن والعلاقات
مستمره بالتطور للتاكد من انها ستعزز
مصالحنا
دكتور وليد يعني سابدا من النقطه التي
انهيت قبل قليل وهو موضوع العلاقات
السعوديه الامريكيه بالرغم من المطبات
التي تمر بها هذه العلاقه ولكن هناك قناه
عراسخه ان كان عند الامريكيين او عند
السعوديين والشرق الاوسط بان هذه العلاقه
هي استراتيجيه وليست مبنيه على اساس ملف
او موقف هذا التاكيد اليوم على ثبات هذه
العلاقه التي تعود يعني لعقود من الزمن ما
معناه بهذه اللحظه بالذات
سيدتي بين العلاقه بحداتها وهي علاقه
مؤسساتيه تاريخيه عمرها عقود
والاطراف تعود اليها الاطراف يعني طبعا
قيادات السعوديه المتتاليه والادارات
الامريكيه المتتاليه هنالك بعض الادارات
ذهبت في هذا العلاقه الى اعلى المستويات
واقرب المواقف كاداره بوش مثلا واداره
الترام كما راينا وهنالك اداره مع العلم
بتمسكها بالعلاقه المؤسساتيه بين الدولتين
قد وضعت بعد الضغوطات منها اداره بيبان
ومنها قبل ذلك اداره همم اوباما ولكن
العمق في هذه العلاقه هذا لا يزال ثابت لم
يتغير شيء وبالتالي من يريد ان يعود الى
التقارب كالان وزير بالامكان يعود وهمم
هذه العلاقه ولكن الشيطان في التفاصيل كيف
وماذا وما هي الاجنده وهو ما هو الموقف
المشترك من ايران والموقف المشترك من
المساله الفلسطينيه كل ذلك فيها تفاصيل
احيانا يكون فيها وجهات نظر اما مختلفه
اما متطابقه
التاكيد على ثبات هذه العلاقه ياتي بوقت
دقيق جدا بوقت شهرت الاداره الامريكيه
وايضا الجانب الاسرائيلي موضوع الخيار
العسكري بوجه ايران ساتحدث بالتفصيل عن
هذا الموضوع بعد قليل ولكن
التوقيت يعني باعاده همم التاكيد على هذه
العلاقات بما تمر به المنطقه العالم
العلاقات الصينيه الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وكل ما الى هناك الى اي مدى هو
مفيد لواشنطن وللمنطقه ايضا
اولا التغيير الكبير الذي جرى هو سيره
الحرب الاوكرانيه ما جرى في اوكرانيا
والعقوبات على روسيا والاجراءات الروسيه
والتحالفات الروسيه مع ايران والصين الى
ما هنالك الكتله الوسط بما فيها التحالف
العربي وبعض الدول الاخرى لكي تكون باتصال
مع الكتلتين كل ذلك الزمن هذه الاداره بان
تسرع الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه كما
راينا في مؤتمر جده وكما الان الان نرى
بهذه الزياره لوزير الخارجيه لانها تريد
المحافظه على المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لانها رقم صعب جدا وهو رقم اساسي في الدول
العربيه اذن الاداره تعود وتؤكد للمملكه
بانه لا يوجد اي اختلاف كبير بين الدولتين
ونحن على ثلاثه قويه ولكن طبعا في اجابه
الاولى الان لنرى في الواقع على الارض كيف
يمكن لي واشنطن والرياضه الثقه فعلا فيما
يتعلق بايران لانه نسمي الاشياء باسمائه
اسمح لي ان انتقل اياك والمشاهدين الى همم
المقاله وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطونيو
بلينكن في لقائه مع العربيه حول النووي
الايراني والتشديد على وجهه نظر اداره
فايدم بانها لن تسمح بامتلاك طهران لسلاح
نووي وايضا اشار الى امكانيه ايجاد حل
دبلوماسي فيما يخص البرنامج النووي
الايراني
نحو الاحداث العديده مثل قمع المظاهرات في
ايران النساء يدافعنا عن حقوقهم ويتم
قمحهن بعنف من قبل النظام وفي نفس الوقت
نرى ايران تدعم روسيا في حربها ضد
اوكرانيا وتقدم لها المسيرات والاسلحه
الاخرى ونرى ايضا ان الدبلوماسيه هي الحل
الوحيد لبرنامج ايران النوويه والرئيس
بايدي كان واضح ان كل الحلول مطروحه لمنع
ايران من الحصول على اسلحه النوويه
اعود اليك دكتور وليد يعني الخيار العسكري
لاحى بجديه عام 2012 وطبعا مع اداره ترامب
ولكن اليوم عاد الجانب الاسرائيلي ليضع
هذا الخيار على الطاوله منعا طبعا وقطعا
لطريق امام امتلاك ايران للسلاح النووي هل
الحل الدبلوماسي مازال قادر على ردع ايران
عن عن امتلاك النووي ام انها حرب نفسيه
يعني نتحدث عن خيار الحرب
وبقوه بموضوع الوصول او العوده الى
الانتفاخ النووي الايراني مع بعض التغيرات
هنا وهناك ولكنها ترى كما جاء في تقديركم
وفي تصريح الوزير الخارجيه امرئا اساسيان
بدا ايه الزان بقدره الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه على انتاج هكذا اول هو وقوف
ايران الى جانب روسيا بشكل اساسي الموقف
الامريكي لانهاء العام لن يفهم كيف توقعون
مع حديث لروسيا وتضعون عقوبات على رؤساء
اثنين وهذا ربما لا اهم الثوره في ايران
يعني الان بعد بدعه اشهر كانت اداره الغير
متاكده ولم تفهم اذا كان النظام الايراني
سوف يعني يقهر هذه المظاهرات ام لا لا
اتبين لا لا وبالتالي فيضعه اي البيت
الابيض يضع هذه المظاهرات في نفس
المعادلات وبالتالي يقول لدينا السيد صغير
يعني لديهم خيط صغير من التفاوض مع نظام
الايراني اما ان يقوم ببعض المحاولات
دي اتش الشارع واذا لم ينجح ذلك عندها
تكون الخيارات
دكتور وليد بهذه النقطه تحديدا يعني
واشنطن كانت تقول بان انشطه ايران وامتلاك
للنووي تهدد مصالح الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها بالشرق الاوسط اليوم مع انتقال
هذا التهديد وتوسعه من الشرق الاوسط الى
البحر الاسود اتحدث هناك عن الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وعن تنامي العلاقات الروسيه
الايرانيه والشراكه العسكريه التي بدات
تخيف الاوروبيين والامريكيين هل ممكن لهذا
التنامي ولهذا الدور ان يدفع اكثر باتجاه
الخيار العسكري
اللعبه الايراني اولوجي الاتفاق نووي
الايراني يضغط بشكل يعني غير طبيعي على
المصالح الامريكيه وعلى جزء من الاداره
الامريكيه ولكن لا يزال هنالك تمسك بهذا
الاتفاق ولكن ما يمكن ان يحدث ويغير
الاوضاع هو ان تكون روسيا نفسها تحت مظله
التعامل الايراني الروسي بان تنقل بعض
الاسلحه الى منطقه الشرق الاوسط عبر ايران
هذا سوف يغير كل المعادلات بتقدير هذا لم
يحصل بعد ولكن هنالك خطر وهنالك ترقب كبير
لدى واشنطن في روسيا بعد الصواريخ وبعض
الرادارات الى الاراضي الايرانيه فتتحول
الى قوه على الخليج وتدل على بقعه اخرى
دكتور من عقب من زمان هناك حرب بين الجانب
الاسرائيلي والامريكي مع ايران طبعا تختلف
بالطريقه اتحدث عن حرب ظل همم اسرائيليه
ايرانيه وعن حرب اقتصاديه امريكيه ايرانيه
يعني الحربين لم تستطع ان تمنع ايران من
التمدد في المنطقه ولا بل تمددت اكثر
وانشطه زادت اكثر وهي على عتبه امتلاك اا
اا يعني الاسلحه النوويه هل ما زال الخيار
الدبلوماسيه ف ما همم ما دمنا نتحدث عن
عقد من الزمن لم ينفع
هو الخيار الدبلوماسي مع نظام غير
دبلوماسي راديكالي جذر تغيير استراتيجي لن
ينفعه لم ينفع حتى منذ التفكير باقامه نوع
من شراكه مع النظام الايراني لا في هذا
التفكير الذي بدا في العام 2009 وتوصل الى
اتفاق في العام 2015 ولكن الساعه
الاستراليه التوقيت الاسرائيلي غير
التوقيت الامريكي التوقيت الاسرائيلي هو
اذا شعرت اسرائيل بان ايران وصلت الى موقع
يهددها فهي تقوم بعملياتها باعمالها في
المنطقه ولكن قدرت ان تغير كل الاوضاع مع
مع ايران هذه محدوده جدا تحتاج للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
يعني اسرائيلي اذا ما فعلا مصالحها
القرار بضرب النووي الايراني من المعلوم
ان خارطه النووي الايراني مختلفه ومعقده
اختلافا تام عن النووي العراقي والنوي
السوري الذي ضربته الادارات السابقه
وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن شيء معقد اكثر
تكتيك اكثر وعن التهيء لحرب متعدده
الاطراف هل باستطاعات الامريكي ان يعني ان
يعطي الضوء الاخضر لهذا عمليه
في مركز القياده في البيت الابيض وما هو
تقيمهم الى قرب او عدم قرب بالاتفاق مع
ايران او الى ضغط الكونجرس الذي سوف يبدا
بعد بدعه اسابيع ولكن لا اقول بشكل سريع
جدا
الاسرائيليين ليس بالضروره ان يضربوا فقط
او يركز لكل شيء على المؤسسات النوويه لا
ننسى انه ال- ال- المؤسسات النوويه او هذه
الذخيره النبويه تحتاج الى صواريخ اللي
كانت تتمكن من ان تصل الى اهدافها ربما
التركيز الاسرائيلي يكون عندهم هذه القدره
وقدره عيناها ربما منذ ساعه ان يضربوا
مراكز معينه محدده عمليا قد استعمل
للصواريخ البالستيه ولكن اكثر من ذلك اي
عمل تغيير داخل ايران يحتاج الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه او اكثر ممكن ولكن حتى
هذا الضوء الاخضر سوف يكون محدود بالنسبه
شكرا لك يا دكتور وليد في السياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه حدثنا من 10
مشاهدينا فاصل و نتابع بعضها المقابله
الكامله مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انطونيو برينجلز ونعود لاستقبال التاسعه
[موسيقى]
اعزائي المشاهدين اهلا بكم في هذه
المقابله الخاصه التي نجريها مع وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انتين بلانكين
ولدينرافقوا في هذه الجوله طبعا بداناها
في القاهره ثم سنذهب الى القدس
غير مناسبه للعوده لخطط العمل المشتركات
كيف سوف تعملون لمنع ايران من حيث
كان لايران فرصه للعوده لخطه العمل الشامل
المشتركه في الصيف الماضي لكن لسوء الحظ
رفضت ما طرح على الطاوله وما اتفق عليه من
قبل كافه الاطراف ومن خلال المخترعات
المقدمه الان تركيزه انه يصبح على جمله من
الاشياء التي حدثت منذ فتره
واخرها العمليات القمع المواطنين الابرياء
الشباب والنساء على وجه التحديد في في
ايران الذين كانوا يدافعون عن حقوقهم
الاساسيه
فهناك مساله مهمه تحدث وكنا نراقب ما يتم
من عمليات القمع ومن قبل النظام وكذلك
ايضا انه نواجه نراقب ما تقدمه ايران
لروسيا في حربها مع اوكرانيا من مسيرات
هذا هو مسار التركي
فعاليه بالنسبه لتعاطي الاسره الدوليه
ايران نوويه دبلوماسيه هي التي كانت
موجوده
لعدم وجود ذلك لكن خير الافضل
العسكري تحدثهم عن النظام كان يقوم
بتنفيذي احكام بحقه المتطهرين
بين كيف لكم ان تدعموا
المواطن الذين كانوا يطالبون بالعون من
الغرب والولايات المتحده كنا مع دول اخرى
نقف ونتحدث بصوت عال مع هؤلاء الذين بكل
بساطه يسعون لجعل اصواتهم مسموعه
من خلال العقوبات واجراءات التصنيفات
المختلفه ايضا
لمساعده الشعب الايراني
الحصول على حقوق الاساسيه لدى هذا
بنت همم
الولايات المتحده بالتنسيق مع الخليجي
يرمي لردعي ايران كافه هذه الجهود
العسكريه ده هي تعتمد على مساله الردع اي
التحقق من اين من ان من ان الدوله الغاشيه
سوف تفكر مرتين وان لا تخدم بعمل خاطئ
وحاول نثبت ذلك وان يظهره واننا نقول
باننا مستعدون اذا ما حدث اي عدوان واذا
لم يفلح العدوان سوف نكون على استعداد
للدفاع انفسنا قال الولايات المتحده دائما
الشعوب التي كانت ترغب بتغير الانظمه
لماذا ليس هو واقع الحال كذلك في ايران
اننا ندعم شعب الايراني وهذه القرارات
متروك لهم وليست لنانا ومن الاشياء التي
يود ان النظام الايراني
ان طرفا خارج البلاد اي مصانعت له
الولايات المتحده فهنا فهذا الامر متركا
للشعب الايراني وهم مسؤولون عنه
وقد يعكس مدى الضعف الذي النظر اود ان
انتقل الى الحديث عن المملكه العربيه
السعوديه كيف تصفون طبيعه العلاقات مع
السعوديه بعد
قرار اوبك بلس فيما يتعلق بالانتاج قلتم
بانكم سوف تراجعون العلاقات مع السعوديه
لدينا علاقه مهمه مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
انها علاقه ما تزال في قيد التطور سوف
نعمل كل مبعوثا للتاكد من ان هذه العلاقه
تعكس مصالحنا
دائما مستمر
وكانت لدينا بعض المخاوف حول القرار التي
اتخذت من قبل ذلك الحين كانت سعوديه اظهرت
علامات ايجابيه مثلا دعمها الواضح
لاوكرانيا في وجه
الغزو الروسي الغاشم
بما يتماشى مع ميثاق الامم المتحده في
مواجهه
العدوان الروسي وتعيدها لقرارات مجلس
الامن وكذلك دعمها الانسانيه في اليمن هذه
الامور مهمه لكنها علاقه مستمره سوف ننظر
اليها على الدوام للتاكد من انها سوف تعمل
على تعزيز المصالح ان هناك جمله من
القضايا في المنطقه العراق لديه رئيس
وزراء جديد السيد السوداني كيف يمكن
مساعدته اذا كنتم ترغبون في تفويض النفوذ
الايراني في العراق لقد تحدثت الى رئيس
الوزراء السوداني
بشده مع الحكومه العراقيه هناك امران اولا
انا هنا ان نرغب من هذه العلاقه ان تستمر
في التصدي الابداعش
ومن خل وكنا قد اخذنا بعض الاجراءات التي
من شانها ضماني وتعزيز قدرات وقوات الامن
العراقيه ليكون لديها الاستعداد والقدره
لمواجهه 11 لكننا ايضا لدينا شراكه واسعه
النطاق الى حدود اكبر فلدينا علاقه
استراتيجيه من خلال العمل مع العراق
ايضا للعراق ان يستمر في
الانخراط الكامل مع
العلم العربي بصوره كامله ليلعب دورا
كبيرا بحاله مصر في ليبيا هل ترون حكومتا
مختلفتان واحده في بن غدد وفي بني غازي
وثانيه في طرابلس ما ندعمه في هذه المرحله
هو الحجر للتوجه للانتخابات بحيث يكون
هناك حكومه شرعيه وواضحه
الشعب الايراني
في تركيا هل تدعمون على العمليه الهجوميه
التي تقوم بها تركيا في المنطقه كيف تحقيق
مقاربه في هذا الامر مسالتان عندما يتعلق
الامر بسوريا فقط حطينا كافه الاطراف على
عدم الانخراطي في اي متاعب هو لم نؤيد على
العمل العمل الاثر العسكري التركي في
سوريا لانه هذا سوف يؤثر على المدن وسوف
يعرقل الجهود التي ترمي لابعاد خطر داعش
ويبعدوا التركيز عن هذا الامر
ليس من مصلحه اي طرف ان تم هذا الامر لدى
تركيا مصالح شرعيه ولا يوجد اي جدلا حول
هذا الامر لكن هذه المصالح
عمل العسكري بشان الاسد
نظام الاسد كنا واضحين فنحن لا نؤيدوا
تطبيع العلاقات مع حكومه الاسد والتحديات
هي
الامم المتحده كانت اقترحت اجراءات
تعتمدوا على خطوه تلوى الخطوه وفقا لقارات
مجلس الامن خارطه سياسيه للمستقبل
ننتقل الى رام الله والقدس كيف يمكن
التوتر هل ترون ان هناك انتفاضه مقبله كيف
يمكن التوصل لمخزن
سوف نتحدث عنها عن هذا الامر خلال اليومين
المقبلين وكما تعلمون راينا عمليات هجوميه
ارهابيه مروعه خلال الايام الماضيه
وقدناها وتحدث الرئيس
فقدان لحياه بعض
المدني وهو امر معرق
الامر الاكثر اهميه في على المدى القصير
هو ان نحاول التوصل الى نوع من الهدوء
لكنني
لكنني في اليومين المقبلين سوف تكون لدي
فرصه للتحدث مع الحكومه الاسرائيليه ومع
السلطه الفلسطينيه لاسمع من الشعب ايضا
الذي تضرر من هذه الاحباب
شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
في مقابله خاصه ايضا ومع العربيه قال وزير
الخارجيه العراق فؤاد
هناك تهريب للدولار الامريكي من السوق
العراقيه وهي مشكله ليست بالجديده
هناك
وضع واضح انه كان هناك تهريب لدوران
للدولار الامريكي من السوق العراقيه وهذا
العلاقه بتنظيم العرض
وتنظيم الطلب اذا
مساله العرض يخص اجانب العراقي والمؤسسات
الماليه العراقيه من ضمنها البنك المركزي
واجانب الامريكي لكن مساله الطلب هذا غير
شيء اخر
في العراق وقال ان ايران غيرت مجرى
الانهار في السنوات السابقه والحكومات
السابقه لم تتطرق للموضوع
لدراسه هذه المسافه بالنسبه لجانب
الايراني المشكله ليست مساله الحصص
والسدود في الواقع جانب الايراني غيار
مجرى المياه
و وهذه الامور حصلت في السنوات السابقه
ولم تطرح في الواقع هذه الامور من قبل
الحكومات السابقه
فاذا تغير مثلا المياه شيء هو الحصول على
الحصص من المياه شيء اخر وبناء السدود في
اخر
[موسيقى]
انطلقت من الداخل الايراني واستهدفت مصنعا
عسكريا في مدينه اصفهان وهي احدى اهم
المدن الايرانيه من ناحيه الصناعات
العسكريه حيث تضم منشات اهم المنشات
الايرانيه النوويه النظام الايراني اقر
بالهجوم ووصفه بالفاشل وفتح تحقيقا لمعرفه
اسباب هذا الهجوم وظهر الدفاع الايرانيه
اعلنت ان الدفاع الجوي اصاب واحده من
الطائرات المسيره فيما وقعت الطائرتان
الاخريان وانفجر بس يقولون امريكيون قالوا
لي ووصفه جورنا ان اسرائيل استهدفت مجمع
عن دفاعيا بايران بطائرات مسيره وهي اول
عمليه اسرائيليه في عهد واظهرت مقاطع
فيديو لحظه الانفجار الذي بدا قويا نتابعه
[موسيقى]
يا صاحبي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ان الموساد قد يقف وراء الهجوم على مخزن
للمسيرات باصفهان تصريح جاء قبل معلومات
وصفيه طبعا اوكرانيا هي الاخرى علقت على
الحادثه وربطتها بالحرب الجاريه على اراضي
حيث قال مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني ان
استهداف مواقع في اصفهان الايرانيه له صله
مباشره بالحرب في بلادنا وطبعا بالحرب
الدائره مع روسيا
[موسيقى]
كشف وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق في
كتابه عن تفاصيل اتخاذ قرار وتنفيذ عمليه
قتل قائد الحرس الثوري الايراني قاسم
سليمان في بغداد مطلع عام 2020 من قبل
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب ومسؤولين في
ادارته
بعد ثلاث سنوات من الحادث وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه السابق مايك بومب يو يكشف
كواليس عمليه اغتيال قائد الحرس الثوري
الايراني قاسم سليماني القصه بدات حينما
كتب بومبيو رساله الى سليماني هدده فيها
بان امريكا ستحاسبه وستحاسبه ايران على
هجماتها ضد المصالح الامريكيه في العراق
لكن الاخيره لم يرد
على هجماتها ضد المصالح الامريكيه في
العراق بعد ذلك بسنتين وفي منزل ترامب في
فلوريدا الى جانب وزير الدفاع ورئيس
الاركان المشتركه تم تقديم توصيه التاليه
سيدي الرئيس لدينا توصيه لك الهدف هو
الجنرال قاسم سليماني سيدي الرئيس سليماني
مسافر من بيروت الى دمشق ثم بغداد ويطيروا
عبر رحلات تجاريه ونعرف طريقه رحلته انه
يتامر لقتل المزيد من الامريكيين لدينا
الادوات الضروريه لوقف قيادته لهذه الجهود
الاجراميه لقد اسقطوا مسيرتين امريكيتين
اطلقوا صواريخ بالستيه على مملكه العربيه
السعوديه والان قتلوا امريكيا حان الوقت
لوقف حكمه الاجرامي
تحديد الثالث من يناير 2020 موعدا للعمليه
وصل سليمان الى مطار بغداد الدولي حيث
استقبله القيادي في ميليشيا الحشد الشعبي
ابو مهدي المهندس مع انطلاق موكب سليمان
والمهندس كانت مسيره
كيه من طراز ام كيو 9 ريبر تتقفى كل
حركاته معه
مغادره سياره سليمانيه المطار سقطت عليهما
صواريخها الفاير بومبيو كتب ان العمليه في
مجملها استغرقت خمس دقائق فقط دون قلق من
وقوع اصابات جانبيه بين المدنيين لان كل
الخطط تمت بعنايه
قاسم اسامه بلال البوجديني العربيه
استاذ طوني يعني عندما
نتحدث عن اول مسؤول امريكي رفيعه المستوى
يتحدث بهذه الدقه والصراحه عن عمليه طالت
احد اكبر رؤوس النظام الايراني دلالات
بهذا التوقيت هل ممكن ان تحرج اداره ام
انها ستخدم سياسه الضغط التي تمارسها على
النظام الايراني
نعم مساء الخير اولا يعني الهدف من الكتاب
طبعا يعني خلينا نحطه بالسياره
حمل الانتخابيه الرئاسيه المزعم انه ما
يكون بيو بده يطلقه
ليرشح حاله للرئاسه يعني ها او يعني اول
شيء هي بتخدم همم مصلحه اذا بدك
شخص يعني هلا فيك انه طلع الكتاب
في ضربه على ايران
طبعا هلا اكيد منه كان هو متوقع يعني طلع
الكتاب قبل بوقت ما كان فيه عنده يعني
طبعا هو معلومات عن الضربه قاتله
للايرانيين انما طبعا هلا بتجه
هلا ما ننسى انه طاقم فريق اوباما يلي هو
طاقم فريق
كان ردد فعله على اغتيال سليمان يردد فعل
كثير سلبي يعني عبر
يعني والموظفين اللي بعده هلا بمركز عالي
كثير كانوا ضده كما كان ضد تصنيف الحرس
الثوري همم
يا اللي شفناها هذيك النهار في نوع في
التمرين العسكري الضخم اللي صار باسرائيل
المشترك بين الولايات المتحده والجيش
الاسرائيلي طبعا
اداره
باتجاه انه هي عم تفرض ضغوط على ايران كون
ال- ال-
اتفاق المفاوضات الاتفاق الاوراق النووي
متوفي حاليا انما في شغله لازم انتبه انه
الاداره ما عم بتقول انه الضغط هو بديل عن
المفاوضات هو عم بتقول الضغط لا شغل ثاني
واحد له علاقه فقط
بالمسيرات بما كما هي عم تستعمل بالحرب
باوكرانيا واحد ثاني يعني هي الى علاقه
مثل ما قال احد همم
الابواب تبع الاداره اللي كان هو مسؤول
سابق سفير سابق باسرائيل لاداره اوباما
عسكري
[موسيقى]
وهاني ارسال رساله ليه استكنان
الوقت اسمح لي ان اخذ جزئيه اخرى عندما
يقول وزير الخارجيه بان العمليه استغرقت
خمس دقائق وبان يعني عن بان حال الوقت
للضغط على الزناد لانه كان يتحضر لعمليات
ضد الامريكيه وبالتالي عندما يتعلق الامر
بالامن القومي الامريكي في المنطقه يعني
يمكن للاداره الامريكيه ان تتخذ قرار وهو
سهل جدا لتصفيه اي شخصيات كانت ولكن يعني
النظام الايراني يهدد كل المنطقه من
الخليج الى دول كل شرق الاوسط لم نرى اي
قرار مماثل بهذا الامر لا يعني يحرج
الاداره مع خلفاء
هذه الاداره طبعا اداره ترامب يعني اخذت
قرار تاريخي بهذا الموضوع يعني نطقنا حملت
مسؤوليه الهجمات على ال ال
الولايات المتحده حملتها لايران ما بقى
نلعب انه بمساله انه هايدي الميليشيات
ونضرب نحن مثلا دربي بالصحراء السوريه او
بالصحراء العراقيه او الى ما هنالك راح
وا ضغط راس الحيه وضربوه بكل وضوح مثل
بيقول كتابه
الحلفاء العرب والاسرائيليين
ااا بالضربه طبعا الامكانيات في خرا يعني
الولايات المتحده عندها حضور عسكري
بالعراق وبالمنطقه ككل يعني الامكانيات
طبعا دائما موجوده
صار في يعني في معلومات اتت من مصادر
سعوديه انه حتى بعد الضرب يعني كان في بعد
ما ضربت ايران همم
[موسيقى]
السعوديه همم قدم ذلك ترامب يعني عربي اذا
بدك همم نوع من همم يعني همم رد على همم
على المملكه والمملكه هي اتفضل اتعدم
التصعيد بحسب مصادر سعوديه اعلى
هون عم بغير ديني يعني عم نحكي هون باداره
هلا ملاحق اذا بدك من فرق اغتيال ايرانيه
في الولايات المتحده وبعدها هذه الاداره
عم بتفاوض معنا الحرس وعم تعطوني المصاري
يعني طبعا يعني في فرقع بين الاداره
السابقه وهذه الاداره اجتماعيه
مشاهدينا كم قبل ان اكمل اسمحوا لي ان
انتقل الى هذه الصور التي بثها قبل قليل
التلفزيون الايراني عن المسيره التي ضربت
استهدفت مصنعا في اصبحان صباح اليوم
هذا الهجوم الذي استهدف مصنع
لتصنيع الاسلحه في اصفهان عبر مسيره كان
قد يعني صدر تقارير عجه عنه وتاكد بانه
حصل من داخل ايران طبعا هناك همم
تلميح لان الموساد هو من قام بهذه العمليه
وطبعا هذا التلميح صدرها عن الجانب
الامريكي وياتي بتوقيت حساس جدا بظل الرفض
الاميركي لتدخل ايران بالحرب الدائره في
بين اوكرانيا وروسيا بعد امدادها
بالمسيرات الايرانيه اذا كان نشاهد هذه
القطاع الاوليه التي تم جمعها للمسيره
التي اطلق على هذا المصنع والذي طبعا كنا
قد شاهدنا ذوي الانفجار الكبير الذي همم
دوه هناك قبل ظهور اليوم
ما بين الامس واليوم يعود سجل الهجمات على
البعثات الاجنبيه في ايران مع مقتل مسؤول
جهاز الامن في سفاره اذربيجان بالعاصمه
طهران في هجوم المسلح وصفات هوباكو
بالارهابي ولاحقا اخلد اذربيجان سفاراتها
في طهران واجلت كامل الفريق الدبلوماسي من
ايران محمله طبعا النظام الايراني
المسؤوليه الكامله عن الهجوم المسلح ولعل
مشاهدينا هذه الحادثه تؤكد تخصص سهران في
ترهيب الدبلوماسيين الاجانب في السياق
طبعا التوتر الذي يطرا على علاقات طهران
والمجتمع الدولي هجمات ارتفع مستواها خلال
العقود الاربعه الماضيه وفقه معارضين
ومواقع ايرانيه علقوا على الحادثه الاخيره
بانها تعكس مدى هشاشه النظام الايراني في
علاقاته الديبلوماسيه
ويبقى هؤلاء مدفوعين من الحرس الثوري
والانظمه التي حصلت همم لا تزال طبعا في
حقبتها الهجمات على السفارات على مدى
العقل هنا نعود لاسوا حادثه في تاريخ
الهجمات على السفارات والقنصليات التي
تعود الى اقتحام السفاره الامريكيه في
نوفمبر من العام 1979 على يد مجموعه من
المتشددين من انصار الخميني بعد فتره
قصيره من سقوط الشاه يومها اختطف مو ولو
نظام 52 امريكيا وغالبيتهم طبعا
دبلوماسيين
يوما تم احتجازهم حتى تم اطلاق سراحهم في
20 من يناير من العام 1981 حيث طبعا
طالبوا طالب منفذوه العمليه الولايات
المتحده بتسليم الشاه رضا بهلوي لتتم
محاكمه الشاه في ايران مقابل الافراج عن
الرهائن وهو الذي لم يحصل طبعا
ايران تاريخ من الاعتداءات على السفارات
والبعثات دبلوماسيه عام
1979 اقتحام السفاره الامريكيه بتهران
واحتجاز رهائن امريكيين لمده 440 يوما عام
1987 اعتداء على مقر السفاره السعوديه في
طهران عام
1988 متظاهرون يهاجمون السفاره الاتحاد
السوفيتي حينها عام 2009 متظاهرون
ايرانيون يهاجمون السفاره الباكستانيه في
طهران عام 2011 اقتحام السفاره البريطانيه
بعد فرض عقوبات بسبب برنامج
عام 2016
وفي تطورات الميدانيه المتعلقه بالحرب في
اوكرانيا قالت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان
الوضع في الشرق صعب لكنها تحت السيطره قبل
ذلك على الجيش الاوكراني ان القوات الصدمه
في منطقه بلاهودات في الجزء الشرقي من
منطقه الاعلان في وقت قالت في جماعه
العسكريه الروسيه عبر تطبيق تيليجرام انها
سيطره على بلا هدتني بشكل كامل
[موسيقى]
المعركه الكبرى في اوكرانيا ستبدا خلال
الاشهر القليله المقبله والسؤال الذي يطرح
نفسه هنا من سيضرب اولا وايت سؤال طرحته
صحيفه الجاردن بريطانيا
الذي يبلغ طوله 1200 كيلو متر ومن المتوقع
وفق خبراء عسكريين تحدثوا للجاردن ان
تندلع هناك اشد مراحل حرب ضراوه منذ بدايه
الحرب وفي انتظار اطلاق شراره الحرب
وشراره المعركه القادمه روسيا تعمل على
تقويه قواتها عبر تحريك وتوجيه اقتصاد
البلاد نحو الصناعه الحربيه من اجل انتاج
طبعا دبابات وصواريخ جديده وفقا لهؤلاء
الخبراء بعدما مثلت المرحله الاولى من
العمليه العسكريه حرب استنزاف كبيره
للجانب الروسي اا طبعا الكريم كلفته الاف
الجنود بالاضافه الى الخسائر التي لحقت
بالترسانه الصاروخيه التي استخدمت فيها
واستخدمت بقصف البنيه التحتيه للطاقه
باوكرانيا اما الجانب الاوكراني فيتحضر
لاخذ زمام المبادره والشروع بالهجوم اولا
والسباق الهجمات الروسيه ولكن غياب
الاسلحه الثقيله لاختراق المواقع الروسيه
يتسبب لها بحاله احباط الا اذا كان
للدبابات الغربيه التي استلمتها مؤخرا
كلام اخر هناك ثلاث جبهات يمكن ان تكون
ساحه للمعارك الضاريه في الربيع المقبل
ويمكن ان يكون حسم اي واحده منها ومنعرجا
حاسما لهذه الحرب جبهه الشرق وهنا نتحدث
عن لهانسك ودنياسك التي كانت مسرحا لاشد
المعارك في الاشهر القليله الماضيه وهي
طبعا اكثر الاماكن احتماليه لشنها جمال
كبرى من كلا يعني بين في الربيع المقبل
جبهه الجنوب في اتجاه جزيره القرم طبعا
وهي الجبهه الاهم بالنسبه للطرفين
الاوكراني والروسيه لانها طبعا ستقرر
نتيجه الحرب برمتها سواء شنت القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه الهجوم الاول في الشرق
ام لا وتبقى طبعا جبهه الشمال حيث تحشت
روسيا قواتها للتدريب بيلاروسيا ولكن يبقى
هذا الامر خدعه من قبل موسكو لابعاد
القوات الاوكرانيه عن الجنوب والشرق بحسب
الصحيفه
[تصفيق]
يتفقوا عسكريون غربيون ان الحرب في
اوكرانيا في طريقها للتوسع والانتقال الى
حرب مدمره ويعزون السبب للبدء بوصول اسلحه
غربيه ثقيله الى اوكرانيا الدعم الغربي
ولكيف نقل الاخيره من الدفاع الى الهجوم
نحو عشرات الدبابات يتامل الغرب ان تغير
وضع القوات الاوكرانيه على الارض بشكل
جذريا لصالحها الا ان مو سكوتر ترد
بتوقعات معاكسه مؤكده ان الدبابات الغربيه
لن تغير المعادله على الارض لا تقتصر
الحزمه الجديده من الاسلحه على دبابات
اليابانز بل انتقلت المساعدات الى المستوى
اخر من الدعم
بالمدرعات من طراز برادلي وسريكر ومضادات
الالغام التوغل في مناطق سيطره الروس
اسلحه هجوميه با
ومقابل كل سلاح غربيا هجومي تضع روسيا
سلاحا رادعا ربما لا يقل شده عن نظيره
وكان الرد الروسي على قرار الاسلحه
الجديده
وبلا من الصواريخ على مدن اوكرانيه ووعدا
بادخال اسلحه اقوى الى ساحه الحرب
وبينما تامر القوات الاوكرانيه ان تشون
هجوما خلال الربيع منتهزه فرصه ان روسيا
تستجمع قواها وتجدد امداداتها من الذخيره
والسلاح يتوقع ان يتخذ الرئيس الروسي
بلادي مير بوتين خطوه السباقيه قبل حزمه
المساعدات العسكريه ويشونه هجوما جديدا
على اوكرانيا في فبراير القادم بحسب ما
نشرتهن الحرب ستكون في ذروتها ولا ربما
ستمتد حمامها لدول الجوار ايضا اذا عمر
العربيه
كشف تقرير لصديقه انا اكثر من 40% من
مساحه اوكرانيا ملوثه بالالغام واصبحت
الان من اكثر الدول التي تحوي الغما في
العالم بعد اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا حيث
تمت زراعه الكثير من الالغام الارضيه
والاشواك والمتفجره في مختلف انحاء البلاد
الامر الذي يشكل طبعا تهديدا مميتا
للمدنيين قد يستمر لفتره طويله بعد انتهاء
الحرب وفق التقرير لبريطاني الذي اكد ان
المدن الاوكرانيه المحرره حديثا ستبقى
خطره لفتره طويله بعد ما اكتشفت عددا
كبيرا من اسلاك التعثر والافخاخ المتفجره
وكذلك المتفجرات المضاده للدبابات الجاهزه
لانفجار التي وضعتها القوات الروسيه اثناء
انسحابها من هذه المدن
[موسيقى]
يضغطوا عدد من المسؤولين العسكريين بهدوء
على البنتاجون الموافقه على ارسال طائرات
اف 16 الى اوكرانيا حسب ما نقلت صحيفه
بوليتكو عن مصادر مطلعه على المناقشات
الجاريه في هذا الخصوص مشاهدين قال مسؤول
كبير في وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه للصحيفه
لا تعارض الامر غير انه لم يؤكد صدور اي
قرار نهائي حول الموضوع وشدد على ان
اوكرانيا لم تعلم بعد ان هذه الطائرات
المقاتله تمثل الاولويه القصوى مشيرا الى
ان تنتجون يركز طبعا على ارسال القدرات
التي تحتاجها كاف في المعارك الجاريه كان
انظمه الدفاع والمدفعيه اذا فالحصول على
مقاتلات اف 16 لم يعد حلما مستحيلا
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا التي تتامل ان تكون هذه
المقاتلات الامريكيه هي الخطوه التاليه من
الدعم الغربي بعد خطوه الدبابات وهذا
الاحتمال ليس مستبعدا ومن الممكن ان يحصل
بالفعل وترسلها واشنطن لعده بقى ابرز هذه
الاسباب ان اكياس تعول على مسانده كبيره
من الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه اضافه طبعا
لدعم مسؤولين جمهوريين لهذا الموضوع اضافه
الى الاستشهاد بالتحولات الاخيره لمستوى
المساعدات الامريكيه للجيش الاوكراني فمع
بدايه الهجوم الروسي كان ارسال الاسلحه
المضاده للدبابات والطائرات كاد جافلن
والسنجر مستحيله لكن كيف حصلت عليها بعد
ذلك ثم اتت المعارضه الداخليه حول ارسال
انظمه الجويه ومع استمرار الضغط الاوكراني
والغربي ودعم عدد من المسؤولين حصلت ايضا
كاف على هذه الانظمه الجويه كذلك الامر
بالنسبه طبعا للدبابات من طراز ولا يوبار
التي كانت شبه مستحيله سيامه مع المعارضه
الشديده داخل الولايات المتحده
لكن ما بعد الضغط الا الانفراج واخيرا
الغرب وفقه والهاله عروض الدبابات على كاف
وهو ما قد يتغير بالنسبه لمقاتلات اف 16
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا ختام التاسعه مع العناوين
لمنع ايران من الوصول للسلاح النووي
ين والاسرائيليين يمكن للعربيه ساتحدث مع
الجانبين لخفض التصعيد
[موسيقى]
بمسيرات انطلقت من الداخل الايراني تاكيد
الامريكي على ان اسرائيل هي من نفذ الهجوم
على اصفهان
وفي كتابه مذكرات ماي بومبيو عمليه قتل
قاسم سليماني استغرقت خمس دقائق فقط
مشاهدينا الى هنا اتى الى ختام التاسعه
لكن اخبار العربيه مستمره والان الى 360
مع الزميل طاهر طاهر ماذا لديك مساء الخير
مساء النور
الى المنطقه ومقابلتنا الخاصه معه بطبيعه
الحال همم توقيع اتفاق النفط الجديد في
ليبيا مع شركه الايطاليه والكثير من
الانقسامات الليبيه حول هذا الموضوع اضافه
الى ضربه اصفها